foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the Exuma Keys Land and Sea Park in the
Bahamas is one of the oldest Marine
protected areas in the world a man-made
sanctuary in the sea the waters team
with life from the smallest to the
largest creature in the food chain
because they are protected from the most
efficient Predator our oceans have ever
known
thank you
[Music]
foreign
cars to fly straight out what's that
probably a bat look there okay
we put this fish here
I came into this because
in a very small
and very limited way I was a hunter of
fish
my first salmon
my first salmon also the largest I ever
caught here I come on a Welsh River 23
pounds
I was chuffed to bits to catch that huge
thing
I have never been more
proud of myself
it was the last that anybody caught on
that beat for years and years I don't
think anybody's caught one as big as
that
since
and I was triumphant but I also have
felt guilty about that fish ever since
because it was one of the last of a
Spring Run that now no longer happens
now why were fewer of them coming back
well I didn't know but I thought I
better find out that that's really what
set me off
on this journey to find out
what was happening to fish in the sea
it's Clover Charles Clover I've got some
queries
box what is the tuna that you serve
which ocean is it from and how is it
caught
as a journalist what changed my view of
the scene is when I walked into the
wrong press conference in The Hague in
1990 and this was the first presentation
I'd ever seen about the effect of
trawling upon the seabed and upon this
creatures that lived on it
and what they said was that trawling
with a bean trawler was like plowing a
field seven times a year
and I'm a farmer's son and I thought to
myself
how many crops would grow if you plowed
that field seven times a year and I
thought not very much at all
and that changed my whole view of what
was going on the scene
our view of the sea has always been that
it is huge beautiful and inexhaustible
[Music]
oh
the oceans are the common Heritage of
all mankind and for billions of years
there have been full of life
[Music]
these huge resources these that we once
believed to be renewable that our whole
human history has led us up to now to
believe that our renewable are not
renewable anymore because of what we're
doing to them and so uh our entire
philosophical approach has to change
it's not going to be the same in the
future as it was in the past that's
where we are now
[Music]
every time
thank you
we never used to think about where our
fish came from but in fact they are wild
animals
and we found that out to our cost for
the first time in Newfoundland
for centuries the waters in Northern
Canada teamed with unbelievable amounts
of cod fish Legend had it that you could
walk across their backs on the water
the Cod was so plentiful the communities
thrived on fishing
as the years went on technology improved
the boats got bigger and catches
increased
the bounties seemed endless
then in 1992 the unthinkable happened
in St John's tonight angry fishermen
vented their rage they charged the room
where John Crosby was holding a news
conference but security would not let
them in what had once been the most
abundant Cod population in the world had
been fished out of existence I've
decided that effective at midnight
tonight there will be a moratorium and
harvesting of Northern Khan until the
spring of 1994. either we cooperate in
addressing it or there's going to be no
fish for anybody no fish for the
Europeans no fish for the Canadians and
an ecological catastrophe on our hands
went out June
you're gonna be me every fisherman on
this island work on fishing
overnight forty thousand people lost
their jobs
the Cod is gone and I think within the
context of cod
particularly in the Canadian perspective
is that this is a species that has been
fished for centuries and centuries Cod
was the reason that people migrated from
the UK from Europe northern France
particular to Canada it was because of
cod
the fishing ban brought the people to
the streets they hoped that one day the
Cod would return
the significance didn't drop it didn't
dawn on anybody too much later today
there are so few left that there they've
got endangered status in Canada and the
Cod populations have not rebounded
despite a moratorium on cod fishing
since 1992.
in 2007 This research vessel sent two
lines each with 1500 hooks to find out
how many Cod were left in the waters off
Eastern Canada
on the first line they caught one small
cod fish
on the second a small basketball
the Cod stocks had been depleted to such
a low level that they were unable to
recover
Newfoundland for a community for which
the whole reason for its existence was
Cod
there's this historical ingrained
element it's part of society permeates
society and the loss of the fish was
basically akin to sort of a loss of soul
and it still remains that 15 years later
after the collapse of the Cod a new
breed of fishery scientists started to
investigate what had been happening to
all the fish in every ocean of the world
amen
foreign
[Music]
catches of fish had been declining
almost everywhere
but what puzzled the scientists in 2001
was that the total World catch kept
going up enough it didn't make sense
the concerns that people had expressed
that local stocks were going down
everywhere but that Global statistics
are showing an increase that this was a
discrepancy
Daniel Pauley a leading expert in global
fishing was asked by the United Nations
food and agricultural organization to
investigate this mystery Daniel Poley
had the Brilliance to start examining
why in the face of the evidence that you
saw in front of you locally
and in the face of of evidence like
Newfoundland that the figures kept going
on
it was when Paulie and his colleagues
looked at the reported catches from
China that they found their answer
for every part of the world the
reporting
was right except for Chinese Waters
when Daniel Polly came to this
department and he said I think they're
wrong I said what do you mean they're
wrong as well it can't be that China is
catching that much
and they found that actually when you
looked at the biological productivity of
the scene what we know about it
everywhere else
the Chinese figures could not be right
they were just made up they were made up
by communist officials who only got
preferment
if the graphs went up graphs kept going
up because they kept making up the
figures and it was a huge seismic moment
we concluded that they were so bass
upward so much that
if you corrected for this effect the
world catch would not be increasing but
decreasing
[Music]
first time in human history the future
of the food the world gets from the sea
was in doubt send a shiver down my spine
because that was the one thing that a
lot of people were holding on to well
things may be bad but at least the
catching lots and the catching more
every year so you know it can't be that
bad from about 1988 we now realize
um it was on the way down and we only
figured that out in 2002 all of these
things were like warning signals and
they were telling a story
in aspects this is a story that was
going on at the same time as a human
influences elsewhere but it's been told
late it's been told we haven't had so
much time to do something about it now
it's honest and now in the next maybe 40
50 years it's crisis it's Crash it's do
something about it time and that's why
this is arguably one of the biggest
problems in the world
[Music]
thank you
man has been hunting fish in the sea
since he discovered they were there
[Music]
foreign
Thousand Years these men and their
forefathers have expected giant bluefin
tuna to migrate from the Atlantic Ocean
to the Mediterranean Sea
and every spring the fishermen set their
track an ancient method of fishing known
as the al-madrado
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
foreign
fisherman once used to catch thousands
of bluefin
but over the last 10 years their catches
have declined by 80 percent
Hallelujah
all right
Euphoria no
well yeah
moment
is
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on the other side of the world in Canada
scientist Boris worm had been trying to
work out how many tuna and other large
fish were left in the sea
somebody said counting fish is just as
easy as counting trees just that they're
invisible they move so it's a it's an
almost impossible thing to do especially
when you want to assess how the global
ocean has changed the whole thing
we asked that very simple question where
are we now relative to a baseline that
we set around 1950 because large-scale
industrialized fishing started around
1950.
so here in 1952 when this series starts
we see that around Japan there's already
blue colors dominating meaning that the
catch rates were low around one fish per
hundred hooks in areas that were newly
exploited we see Catch rates about 10
times higher
10 or more fish per 100 hooks
worm used Japanese fishing fleet data
that had recorded how many fish were
caught on every 100 hooks they set
first time industrial Longline Fisheries
went out into the open ocean and just
worked through the whole ecosystem
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
has reached a truly Global coverage and
a lot of the ocean is it the blue colors
now meaning the abundance of these large
fish globally has probably declined by
about 90 this has been widely criticized
and there have been many Papers written
to undermine attack these findings
totally wrong
that's there's just no question that's
some Fisheries scientists felt that
worms findings didn't reflect their
local situation
some thought that even attempting to
count how many large fish were left in
all the oceans was an impossible test
I think that in their haste to get the
big picture
they they don't look carefully enough at
at local places they actually disagree
with one thing certain tuna Yellowfin
and skipjack in the Pacific and there
they say it's only 70 percent not 90
whether it's 90 or 95 or 80 or 70 is
rather irrelevant we all know they've
declined dramatically so focusing on the
particulars in that
in that sense is is not helpful
the overall Trends in worms findings
were reflected in official data
species after species had collapsed
[Music]
everybody recognizes that there's major
problems in the world's fisheries and uh
and at one level it's a question of how
you know of how bad is it
[Applause]
[Music]
today in every ocean of the world
high-tech industrial vessels are hunting
down every known edible species of fish
the basic problem in most Fisheries that
are in trouble is too too many boats too
much capacity chasing too few fish
Global fishing capacity could catch the
world catch four times over
the world's long-lining industry sets
1.4 billion hooks every year
these are estimated to be set on enough
line to encircle the globe more than 550
times
the mouth of the largest trawling net in
the world is big enough to accommodate
747s we are fighting a war against fish
right and we are throwing at them our
industry and we are winning
and that's how we perceive our
interaction with them
because we're too good right logically
not a single hunted animal on this Earth
has a chance
these vessels are equipped with so much
electronic equipment that they the fish
have actually no chance of escaping
Skipper knows exactly where he is in
relationship to a rock where fish could
hide in relationship to a wreck where
fish would be attracted to
it doesn't take very long for us to have
very serious consequences in what we're
doing
we're not willing we keep pressing the
button we're not willing to hold back
[Music]
the might of the fishing Armory has
grown exponentially in the last 50 years
fishing power that we have at our
Command today
far outweighs our ability to control
ourselves
fishing has transformed entire
ecosystems in fact I would say one of
the largest
scale transformation of the planetary
environment has been the impact of
bottom trawlers
Nets that are dragged across the seabed
and as they are pulled they cut down the
animals that live on the surface things
like corals and sea fans and sponges but
the signs of Destruction brought up on
Deck by the troll would make an angel
weep
[Music]
if the fishing effort continued to
increase continue to be directed at the
dwindling resource you would of course
catch most of it
[Music]
the blue fin is one of the most iconic
fish in the sea its beautiful
hydrodynamic shape in specially heated
blood allow it to accelerate faster than
a supercar
pound for pound its delicious flesh is
the most expensive and sought after on
the planet
the Bluefin once sustained Roman Legions
in battle
now it feeds fashion conscious diners
and sushi restaurants around the world
[Music]
Bluefin is a front line proof Bluefin is
is
the most immediate crisis that we know
about for many years scientists have
been predicting that the king of the
tuna would be hunted to Extinction but
now it is actually happening
[Music]
Roberto mielgo is a bluefin tuna
fisherman who has turned whistleblower
on an industry he believes is out of
control
alone presence in the ports of Europe
milgo is hunting for information to
bring the slaughter to a halt
[Music]
I can I can actually tell from here it's
bluefin
I started in this business as a as a
tuner Farm diver that was many years ago
those days were the good old days where
the stock was healthy I would say but
then bluefin tuna became big business
I mean really big business in 2002 I was
in Tunisia I think it was and that's
when I first sensed that something
terribly wrong
was happening the conflict was that I
started something I could not control
and as from there
I took the decision to try and do the
right thing
that is a bluefin uh unloading
let's say let's say there's only two
containers
and they jam-packed those two reefer
containers 40 feet refill containers
28 times each
that is 50 56 tons of fish
which is more
than what Taiwan would normally declare
as catches at the end of the fishing
season
so there you go I mean just one boat
what's the stake here is of an Infamous
minority of people making millions and
millions and millions
by decimating a specie is that right is
that moral
[Music]
in Luxembourg European Union ministers
meet to decide the fate of the fish and
the industry which depends on
[Music]
Patrol through internationally agreed
quotas the amount fishermen are allowed
to catch
these are recommended by scientists
[Music]
what will happen this afternoon
and what it will mean for the gluten
tuna well
the decision that goes against an
irrational scientific advice for the
conservation of
Bluefin scientists are recommending a
catch of 15 000 tons simply to avoid
collapse in order to rebuild the fish
population the catch needs to be less at
ten thousand tons but ministers vote for
a catch of 29 500 tons twice what it
should be to keep the population from
crashing and three times what it should
be to let the fish recover I just can't
accept that this is a political quota
it's it's it's
negotiating with Biology and you just
can't do that and expect to see the
biology survive this is a species which
is is endangered as the white rhinoceros
and yet it's being hunted to Extinction
in the Mediterranean
it's being exploited at more than twice
the levels it should be and those
countries that have overfished it and
not being forced to pay back what
they've ever fished so not a day in
which the European Union has covered
itself in glory bluefin tuna is not the
only fish whose stocks have declined
dramatically and most of the others have
declined while under the supervision of
the scientists and politicians in the
richest nations of the world
fishery managers were engineers they
would have been fired long ago because
uh you know we'd be having collapsing
buildings and bridges all over the place
because the calculations are so far out
and so it's not a question of if uh fish
stocks will collapse uh when you make
decisions like that it's a question
simply of when collapse is inevitable
[Music]
this is the center of the bluefin tuna
universe
Malta is that
[Music]
Roberto mielglo has come to Malta to
investigate whether the tuna industry is
catching more than the quota allows
[Music]
hello Charles how you doing how are you
getting on oh well busy have you found a
lot oh quantity
despite the scientists recommending an
annual catch of 15 000 tons and the
politicians setting 30 000 tons official
figures show that the Mediterranean
bluefin tuna industry simply ignores the
regulations and catches 61 000 tons a
third of the entire bluefin tuna
population
[Music]
discovers that some fishermen will stop
at nothing to get hold of this sought
after commodity I flew to lampedusa the
other day and just by chance I came
across some interesting documents is
there anything to to link them to
up to fishing activity
so they can catch as many fish as
possible The Fleets use planes to spot
the tuna Shoals an activity that has
been outlawed during this part of the
season for the last 10 years
[Music]
mostly these planes were operated by
Italian fishing cleats fishing south of
lampedusa east of Tunisia and outside
Living Waters this is a disgrace the
Italian government isn't doing a thing
nobody is enforcing the rule of law this
is a disgrace for the European Union
[Music]
foreign
the breaking of the rules by fishermen
is one of the biggest problems facing
the world's oceans
illegal unregulated and unreported
fishing is worth up to 25 billion
dollars a year fishermen cheat because
it can fish them cheap because they
don't get caught that's true of all
systems
a study for the House of Lords in the
United Kingdom reported that 50 percent
of the Cod caught in the North Sea was
illegal every other fish on your plate
was stolen stolen from you
[Music]
mialgo has come to Tokyo the center of
the world tuna train where last ditch
attempts are being made to save the
Majestic bluefin
[Music]
every day
the biggest company in the tuna business
is the multinational Mitsubishi makers
of cars and electrical products they
don't actually catch the fish they just
buy it I would think that Mitsubishi
Corporation itself would be in control
of something like 60 percent of all of
the entire bluefin tuna production uh
Northern bluefin tuna production in the
Atlantic and the Mediterranean
is here to attend a meeting of the
international committee for the
conservation of Atlantic tuna icat which
has been called in a desperate attempt
to persuade the industry to stick to
internationally agreed quotas
Roberto speaking here in Tokyo how are
you getting on well
it's been a humbling experience Charles
mielgo had discovered that Mitsubishi
were sending out new larger boats to
bring back bluefin
they have pumped up the freezing and
transportation capacity
Mitsubishi claimed to control less than
40 percent of the Bluefin import market
and say the new boats were sent to
replace old vessels
but mielgo believes that Mitsubishi and
other Traders are building up Frozen
reserves which will be worth much more
if fish stocks are depleted if there's
no more bluefin tuna courts but you're
sitting on sixty seventy thousand tons
of it Frozen
you name the price
Mitsubishi say they try to provide the
Japanese Market with stable supplies at
reasonable prices while supporting
policies to ensure long-term
sustainability of the stock but Niel go
fears that the result will still be the
extinction of the species
the immediate conclusion one has to come
up to is that these guys want to fish
until the very last bluefin tuna once
they have caught the very last bluefin
tuna they will go on to big eye tuna and
once they have overfished both in a big
eye tuna they will go for another tuna
specie
Mitsubishi insists they want to preserve
the tuna for future generations and they
support Cuts in the blue fin quota
the fate of bluefin shows what
multinational corporations International
Fisheries policy and consumer demand can
do to a wild species
but the race to catch the last fish
whatever its price is happening all over
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody
[Music]
inside the person
hundreds of millions of people in the
world depend on fish to keep them alive
for 1.2 billion people it is a key part
of their diet
in West Africa which used to have one of
the richest Seas on the planet the
stocks of fish have declined massively
in the last 50 years
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
is an expert on West African Fisheries
who has come to Senegal to find out what
effect this has had on local people
fish is crucial in in West Africa I mean
the coastal people depend on fish and
even the interior people come down on
the on the farms is upon them on this
drought deserts and so on so it is very
important to keep this going for the
sake of the people because if the fish
goes down the coast of West Africa will
be leated with problems we we cannot
afford to let this go
[Music]
is an artisanal fisherman who lives in
Dakar the capital of Senegal
fishing is his livelihood
[Music]
evening
everybody
[Music]
earns six dollars from his fishing his
fuel cost him four what is left has to
feed his family
meanwhile on the same Shoreline money is
being made
the governments of many developing
countries trade fishing rights for quick
cash from developed Nations
taxpayers from the Western World pay for
the largest fishing boats on the planet
super trawlers to fish the distant
Waters
the locals and their parogues don't
stand a chance
that's no good for the fisherman that's
no good for our sea that's good just for
European fishermen and government
Senegal because we have a lot of money
idar has died the waters off Senegal for
the last 35 years and has witnessed huge
changes to the health of the local ocean
he is campaigning against foreign boats
fishing in his Waters
When I See This I want to fight with
this guy I want to fight with this
industrial boat I want to fight with the
government who take just money and don't
know what to do I want to fight with the
world because it was going to be to be
dead it's not possible fishing is one of
the most wasteful practices on Earth
every year more than 7 million tons a
tenth of the world's cash goes back over
the side dead this includes hundreds of
thousands of turtles seabirds sharks
whales and dolphins see how he do to
destroy his asean
he take just what he wants he take just
what his need to sell now but but the
fish
he don't need to sell that he put him
out and he killed him
look all around you
as the fish have been taken by Foreign
fleets fishermen like adamah have been
left with an impossible decision
should he leave his family and risk the
dangerous journey to Europe
um
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah
[Music]
the fish goes
people are made poorer and what happens
they try to immigrate the Europeans like
our fish but they don't like the people
the fish has visa to come in but the
people attend back
[Music]
please
I think that
man is not going to change
and the Sea going to be dead because man
is crazy we are crazy our our world is
crazy world
[Music]
in the restaurants of Asia diners are
buying live fish in Greater quantities
than ever before
these have been taken from the most
beautiful parts of the planet the coral
triangle
[Music]
the coral triangle is an area of ocean
half the size of the United States and
the Seas of southern Asia
[Music]
coral reefs were targeted as a food
supply when local Waters ran out the
most desirable fish are the Reef's large
colorful predators
[Music]
our insatiable appetite for such
Delicacies threatens to tip the fragile
balance of nature into chaos
we don't know what the implications are
of losing
some of these very
one particular component of the
ecosystem we just know that in other
ecosystems there have been problems and
that when we mess around with nature
there's usually problems
an east coast of America there is a
terrifying clue of what can happen when
you disturb the ocean's natural
equilibrium
we've got a big surprise for you we've
got Chesapeake Ray
most people don't use it as a food
because it's a little difficult to get
to
in Chesapeake Bay there have been
increasing reports of a plague of
biblical proportions a little-known
inhabitant of the bay the cow knows Ray
has exploded in numbers
foreign
scientist Pete Peterson was
investigating the increase in the cow
nosed Ray population when he noticed
that the graph of their growth was the
exact opposite of the graph of the
decline in their main Predator the shark
number of quality scientists will tell
you that that statistics are in some
ways icing on the cake when you do your
science but to tell you the truth as you
look at a plot of how the numbers of
sharks along this Coast have changed how
the numbers of rays skates and smaller
sharks have changed at the same time you
don't need a statistic at all it jumps
right off the page at you when large
predators are taken out when they're
depleted in abundance as much as they
are we have large ecosystem effects that
can cause all sorts of domino effects
throughout the ecosystem a lot of them
surprising unforeseen effects
thank you
there's evidence of this knock-on effect
happening all over the world in
Newfoundland Lobster numbers are
exploding
the loss of cod and other
bottom-dwelling fishes what we have seen
is an increase in the abundance of other
things
so in this part of the Atlantic there's
always been a fair number of lobster but
there's now evidently quite a bit more
so it seems fairly reasonable to
conclude that the decline of cod and
other predatory fishes has
basically paved the way for an increase
in the abundance of those things that
Cod used to eat fishermen have eagerly
fed off the Bonanza there is big money
to be made in Lobster but how long will
it last this is the situation that
happens everywhere we have removed the
fish the large fish in many places what
has exploded is the shrimp shrimp have
exploded this good shrimp good money but
if you'll fish them what then the end
point is when the prawns and the
scallops two have gone we we really will
be down to a highly simplified ecosystem
of mud and worms
jellyfish infestations are increasing
are becoming no-go Zone
our oceans once full of large fish are
now filling up with algae Plankton and
worms
Plankton sticks pressed Into fish-shaped
Pieces perhaps jellyfish Burgers
the options are endless
oh
[Music]
losing species what does that mean for
us what does it mean for society what
does it mean for the predictability of
the global oceans which is 70 of the
planet
and the answer is with every species
that disappears some of those services
are eroding there's less food there's
declining water quality and there's
declining stability of the system would
alarm me the most was that the ability
of the system to absorb shocks and
disasters to deal with climate change to
deal with overfishing was diminishing it
could be a road of no return
according to data collected by the
United Nations the number of fish
species whose populations have crashed
is growing year by year
worm and the other scientists have
projected that if the current trends
continue the stocks of fish which we now
eat will have collapsed by the middle of
the century
what we noticed was the curves that they
were separating the high and low
diversity occurs but they were both
dropping all the fish and invertebrates
that we eat that Supply us with seafood
we found that by 2003 about one-third of
them were in what we call it collapsed
State over the last 50 years there was a
very very clear trend of year after year
after year more of these species were in
that collapse category they started very
high they kept dropping and dropping and
dropping and dropping and if you take
those curves and you say Well they're
dropping when are they going to hit zero
when are they going to drop down to the
point where the Fisheries that we're
used to are no longer going to be
possible and those curves drop down and
they hit zero about 24
this is not some horror scenario it's a
real possibility and it's not rocket
science because if we're depleting one
species after another it's a finite
resource there will be a point in the
future where we will run out if we don't
change the way we treat this Global
resource worm and the others were
criticized by their opponents for naming
a precise date but this was not the
point they were making whoever makes an
extrapolation makes it always
assuming that things remain the same and
I would say that assuming that things
remain the same this prediction that we
will have
no fish in uh in 50 years or so are
essentially correct when the human
population comes under real pressure on
land when we begin to have real problems
with global warming when we start
running out of enough food to feed
ourselves
we have just squandered one of the
greatest resources that we've ever had
on the planet wild fish
that's what it means
[Music]
foreign
for Generations men have hunted the
world's oceans
for Generations we've eaten fish
what can Our Generation do to stop us
reaching the end of the line
[Music]
fish I love fish eating fish than Meats
I can eat fish four times a day my son
doesn't like if I cook fish he said no
Mommy I want chicken and I said fish is
good for the body we said no
I love fish under 102 percent
well I love to eat fish
um so fisher
fisher food to me
[Music]
lots of the time people say well all the
fish 90 of the fish gone where are they
where we have eaten them
that's what we have we have eaten them
[Music]
when we look at a piece of fish on our
plate what do we know about that fish we
know it's good for us we know it's
probably got some omega-3 fatty acids
which are good for all our organ
functions
but what else do we know about it what
do we know about it do we know what
species it is
do we know whether it was caught legally
or illegally or in the waters of some
distant country where the inhabitants
would actually prefer to have caught it
themselves
hello Ingrid uh it's Charles Clover from
The Daily Telegraph I noticed that
Marlin was on the menu this is a kind of
an unusual fish to find on the minute
and I wondered
um which species of marlin this was
because I thought there was an awful lot
of marlin left both these fish the
bluefin tuna and the uh Chilean sea bass
are listed as endangered species I
wanted to talk to someone who would know
about
the sourcing policy for fish at Nobu
restaurants can we send them an email no
we can't
British journalist Charles Clover has
been trying to find out what has sold in
some of the most exclusive restaurants
of the world
after five years of no comment
eventually Nobu agreed to talk
[Music]
hello
Mr Noodle how are you
you've got a a fish that is actively
been described as endangered since 1996.
and you're serving it in your
restaurants not only are we going to
describe what it is on a menu I'm going
to put an asterisk next to it and on the
bottom of the menu I'm going to say you
know it is an endangered
environmentally uh endangered species
just so people know that's the immediate
step that we can do then we also it's
sort of Hard Sell you know it has some
endangered species are people going to
buy that do you think
you're not being informative
at some point people have to make
decisions on their own if you look at a
pack of cigarettes it has warning signs
say this will kill you the the question
people will want to know is why you just
don't take it off the menu now if you've
got
orangutans and you know cheetahs and
lions and tigers and things on that menu
I mean people would you know
they're walking away there'll be a huge
scandals there'll be tabloid stories
about it people would be execrated
people there would be turds on people's
doorsteps and in envelopes being shoved
through them people would you know burn
each other's houses down scratch their
cars and yet we're doing it to things in
the sea and we're doing the same thing
this dish is modern cool refreshing
looks really really like flashy
um but it's dead dead simple so I've got
some beautiful bluefin tuna
now that these kind of popular
television programs with celebrity chefs
have made fish fashionable is it too
late to save the world's oceans
people ask me all the time are you
despairing or are you hopeful and I
saying absolutely hopeful and they ask
what makes you think that and I say well
two things one is uh now we have a much
better understanding than even five
years ago what's going on and there's a
track record of when we understood
changes and
they became public knowledge
they entered people's Consciousness like
with pollution like with ozone depletion
with climate change more recently
things started to happen and people made
changes I think that there's a message
of Hope because there's still time for
us to turn the course of history and
although the the players have taken
poison there's still time to save them
[Music]
Alaska is on the front line in the
battle to conserve fish
according to the UN according to the
only laws that we have of the sea the
sea belongs to us
the citizen
not to the fishermen nor to the
Aggregates industry nor to the oil and
gas Industries it's ours
so why don't we claim it back
[Music]
Alaska has a 200 mile fishing limit
which it strictly enforces
portlock Bank
coordinates are going to be
it appears that they've been fishing in
one area and they're claiming another
[Music]
lessons from Alaska is first you have to
not allow new boats to enter and you
have to find mechanisms to get some
boats to leave to to match your Fleet
size to the capacity of the resource
Alaska's fishing policy is not perfect
but the number of fishing boats here is
carefully controlled and managers can
monitor how much is being caught and
react accordingly
fishing policy here is determined by the
science catch limits are set well below
the level that fish populations can
withstand
one of the differences between Alaska
and let's say the North Sea or is that
the average exploitation rate on stocks
in Alaska is on the order of 10 percent
a year
in the North Sea it's 50 percent
one way in which Alaska controls the
catch is by giving the fishermen a
limited amount of time to fulfill their
quota
[Music]
thank you
if you look at it from just a a personal
perspective sometimes that's there's a
personal sacrifice but if you look at it
from the big picture they gotta take a
cut and harvest but to take that knowing
that it gives you an opportunity to
maybe have a better season two three
four five years from now we just don't
want to catch that fish this year next
year we want to catch it 10 15 20 years
from now
foreign
as consumers we have the power to bring
about a positive change at Sea by
demanding to know where our fish comes
from how it was caught and whether it is
endangered there is a fishing industry
out there some of which is trying
incredibly hard to get it right and they
are not being supported as much as they
should be because people are not
recognizing the difference between what
they're doing or the guys who are just
rampantly raping the seas are doing I
think we have to support that part of
the fishing industry
thank you
for consumers there are guides to
identifying which fish is better to eat
[Music]
then there are labels which certify its
sustainability
one is issued by the Marine Stewardship
Council the MSC what we do in the
choices we make in say supermarkets when
we go to a restaurant actually has a
direct effect
on Marine diversity
at the moment only a small proportion of
the fish we buy comes from a sustainable
source
but with pressure things are slowly
changing
even the world's largest retailer
Walmart has plans to sell only MSC fresh
and frozen fish by 2011.
we sell approximately 20 million pounds
of fresh fish a year we had to do
something that would protect us as we
grow and as we need more and more
product into the future and that's where
the MSC really Shone out to us as a
leading way that we can really Embrace
and grow our resonance
[Music]
bird's eye once the king of the codfish
finger now buys over two-thirds of their
fish from sustainable sources
and Fast Food Outlet McDonald's say that
over 90 percent of their fish comes from
a sustainable source
knowledge is power and what knowledge
gives you is the opportunity to change
the way that you do things to change the
way you behave
more and more fish are now being farmed
many people see this as an answer to the
increasingly desperate problem facing
our oceans but fish farming is not all
that it seems
thank you
[Music]
fish farming uses wild fish to feed
farmed fish but it kills more than it
produces
all of these anchovies will be ground up
for fish meal to feed fish and other
animals around the world
of 100 million tonsils get fish
percent go and get ground into fish meal
to feed other fish and not to feed
people
so that some rich people somewhere in
the world can eat salmon and can eat
shrimp the more
fish farming we do in the west the less
fish we have this is one of the
paradoxes that people have big have
problems understanding
aquaculture for species that eat fish
doesn't have that much room to grow
because there just aren't that many fish
out there in the ocean to feed them
anymore
you actually convert fish from one
species into the other you don't make
more fish at least not when you have
Farm fish on average five kilos of
anchovy make only one kilo of salmon
we've reached the buffers we have
reached the limits what the ocean is
capable of providing to feed the fish
farming industry so how can it grow if
it's already reached the end of its
feedstock
Patricia has started a campaign to
encourage people all over the world to
eat small fish like anchovy Herring and
mackerel instead of the farm fish that
are fed on them why not eat the fish
directly why not eat the anchovies
they're much better for you than salmon
anyways it's this tiny little fish that
has all the energy that you need to to
to be healthy
[Music]
if fish farming is not the answer
despite attempts to make it less
wasteful
and sustainable Fisheries aren't
catching on fast enough what else can we
do to save the world's oceans we need to
turn back the clock 200 years to bring
back life to restore its previous
abundance and productivity in some
places around the world oceans I'm
talking about creating a network of
areas within which we can turn back the
clock
[Music]
it's a nice country
it has been beautiful than this
I decided to die and go to heaven
[Music]
Marine reserves are areas of the world's
oceans where commercial fishing is
completely banned
the results can be staggering
wherever people have established an area
that's off limits to fishing and policed
it well they've been Resolute in their
pursuit of protection
reserves have shown marvelous benefits
[Music]
I studied Marine reserves in the
Caribbean
and there the local community set up for
areas that are off limits to fishing in
1995. over time you could see the reef
repopulating and refilling and life was
becoming more abundant on them and we
saw an increase of three four five times
the amount of fish that were present
initially over a period of seven years
of protection after that
[Music]
Hardy McKinney is a fisherman in South
Andros in the Bahamas campaigning for a
reserve to be set up in an area
decimated by fishing
how this area set aside as a protected
area no one is permitted to go here to
fish and you allow the fish
to do what didn't what they do
it's just a natural thing you would have
more fish so you would go to a rock
where there's one Nassau grouper and
next year you may see two
and then the following year you may see
four
and so you know it naturally it would
work
Marine reserves are
absolutely necessary
but they are necessary and we must have
lots of them the best available
calculation on uh how much it will cost
to have a Global Network of marine
protected areas that recover between 20
and 30 percent of the area of the world
oceans is that it would it would take
about 12 to 14 billion dollars a year to
manage a network of that scale
compare to Fisheries subsidies the the
amount is roughly equivalent The Fishery
subsidies are estimated to be of the
order of about 15 to 30 billion dollars
a year and those subsidies encourage
overfishing what this 12 to 14 billion
dollar cost of managing protected areas
would do would be to contribute to the
solution to overfishing and in the
process would create about a million
jobs worldwide
the world has signed up to establishing
a network of marine protected areas by
2012. some Nations have promised to
protect 20 percent or more of their seas
in the future
but we have to put pressure on
governments to ensure this happens we
have about four thousand Marine reserves
of different sizes in the world
they cover
one less than one percent of the world
ocean point six
point six ninety nine point four percent
of the ocean is fishable you are allowed
to fish
and 99 of the ocean
now that doesn't seem to me to be
a proper representation of our interests
as Citizens
Marine reserves on their own will not
solve the problem of the emptying Seas
fishermen and migratory fish will move
to unprotected areas so these also have
to be controlled
politicians have to act responsibly when
making decisions about the oceans
consumers need to change their eating
habits
and the global fishing industry has to
abide by the rules and reduce its
capacity
the problem is getting political will to
implement these things and people will
always argue well you can't do this
because it would affect too many
people's livelihoods well in the end
those livelihoods are disappearing year
by year with inaction
I want them to manage the sea for
Recovery I want the I want to be full of
fish
I want it to be
full of cold and skating
[Music]
haddock and halibut and you know
shellfish and everything the society
want to see that recovery take place
or is it Society happy with massive
depletions I don't think my six-year-old
daughter is going to be particularly
happy in 10 years time when she reads
about this stuff and learns about it and
says
God all this happened in your lifetimes
in your lifetime my lifetime anyone
who's 30 40 50 60 years old this has
happened on our watch and we have a
collective responsibility
the difference between this and other
environmental problems is it actually it
is relatively simple to solve we can act
now
it's not rocket science we don't need
more knowledge to do so so let's do what
we can where we can you can do it here
you can do it now you just do it
is
[Music]
good
step two shephones
step three
and hold it tight with me
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you